[Musik]
nach zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live auf ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und ein ereignis beginnt heute auf dass
viele menschen die sich gerne mit bällen
beschäftigen sehr lange gewartet haben
denn in einer guten stunde beginnt die
uefa euro 20 20 der name ist programm
fenster haben genau fast ein jahr
verspätung letztes jahr ist die
europameisterschaft der fußball lehrern
ausgefallen pandemie bedingt aber der
name ist geblieben einmal sagt die uefa
damit sie nicht das ganze merchandising
neu drucken müssen also ein bisschen
nachhaltigkeitsgedanke aber auch weil
das turnier eigentlich letztes jahr sein
60-jähriges bestehen gefeiert hätte und
man muss quasi in diesen namen noch
weiter transportieren wollte und die
grundidee dahinter weiß dass man nicht
in einem land spielt wie immer oder
vielleicht in zwei sondern gleich in
zehn ländern in elf stadien
das heißt es ist wirklich eine
europameisterschaft auch geografisch
heute ist das erste spiel türkei gegen
italien 21 uhr ist antrieb und wir
wollen das ganze uns aus verschiedenen
perspektiven anschauen und all eure
fragen beantworten die kommentarspalten
sind offen wie immer ihr kennt das oder
per mail an uns hätte erfreute - live at
zdf.de das landet dann bei mir im studio
und ich habe heute jede menge
fachpersonal eingeladen unter anderem
eine zb sport kollegin katrin
müller-hohenstein hier im studio hallo
kathrin außerdem zugeschaltet ist uns
sven voss den herzogenaurach da hat die
deutsche mannschaft ja ihr quartier
aufgeschlagen und wir schalten nach rom
gleich zum nette hilsenbek und zu
türkischen und italienischen fans hier
in deutschland mal gucken wie die feiern
und überhaupt die große frage ist
wie kann man überhaupt gucken aber wir
beginnen in rom wo es sehr sehr lauten
was uns gesagt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich stehe hier auf dem piazza del
popolo in der mitte der mitten in der
stadt im herzen roms und hier ist sie
offizielle fan-meile das sogenannte
ferndorf aufgebaut wo sich die treffen
dürfen
die keine karten keine tickets im
stadion bekommen haben
auch hier sind das vielleicht 2000
menschen die jeweils in diese person
dürften
und es gibt sehr strenge regeln also
wenn man sich vorher mit einer app
anmelden unter der nummer zugeteilt die
findet man hinter haufen boden wieder
und muss an dieser nummer an diesem
punkte auf den boden dann die ganze zeit
stehen bleiben
ob das bestimmung sagen wird werden wir
sehen momentan hört sich so an als ob es
trotzdem ganz gut funktioniert aber es
sieht im hintergrund ist die ganze zeit
eher im hintergrund sieht es nicht so
aus als ob die menschen jetzt auf ihrem
platz stehen bleiben das sieht eher nach
einem munteren gewusel aus ja vor allen
dingen außerhalb von der von der
absperrung haben sich inzwischen
menschen angesammelt und die halten sich
natürlich nicht an irgendwelche punkte
mit nummern auf dem boden sondern die
stellen sich ganz normal so hin wie man
sich eben immer hinstellt und deswegen
wird sich im lauf des abends erweisen
wie sich das weiter entwickelt auf dem
weg hierher habe ich wahnsinnig viele
fans gesehen natürlich alles azzurri
fans alle im blauen shirts die zu irgend
zu festivitäten gehen meistens wird
hierfür privat gefeiert oder aber in
restaurants oder bars wo man auch gern
teller spaghetti dazu essen kann und mit
freunden diskutieren kann
auch hier heißt es keine großen gruppen
also vier bis sechs leute dürfen früher
seien deswegen haben zum beispiel viele
gastwirte auch keine großen bildschirm
aufgehängt sondern nur kleiner wo eben
eine kleine gruppen sich davor treffen
können um zu vermeiden dass es große
menschenansammlung gibt also alles im
rahmen der sicherheit ob sich das den
ganzen abend durchhalten lässt oder ob
vielleicht die euphorie dann in der so
große wellen schlägt das dann doch alle
wieder zusammen stehen das werden dann
auch sehen wie ist denn das konzept in
italien darf man sich da einfach frei
bewegen auch ohne maske oder ist das
tatsächlich masten pflicht über allen
öffentlichen plätzen
also in italien ist es sogar generell in
den städten in den orten überall noch
masken schlicht hass und natürlich auch
im inneren asien lokalen in geschäften
oder in räumen die gastronomie ist immer
noch nur im außenbereich geöffnet aber
es sind sehr sehr große außenbereich
inzwischen entstanden
und wenn man sich dann hin setzt darf
man auch die maske ab ziehen ansonsten
ja überall mit maske
ich glaube dir ein lustiges bild gerade
eine frage gerade ob das dann würde
nicht passen ob das ein green screen ist
annette hilsenbeck steht tatsächlich
leibhaftig in rom dort auf dieser
kleinen fan meile und das ist alles
nicht gekriegt
wie ist dann generell die korona lager
bei euch in italien design haben hier ja
kontinuierlich abgenommen und die
umfragen sind hoch gegangen und damit
ist diese hat sich die situation
deutlich schafft seit wochen können die
laden menschen ja auch wieder frei atmen
und können auch wieder in restaurants
und bars das ist schon viel früher
losgegangen als in deutschland dass man
auch wieder im außenbereichen von
lokalen sitzen kann dass man in
geschäfte gehen kann und die leute
genießen das sehr sind aber immer noch
sehr vorsichtig und wenn man mit leuten
hier gesprochen hat war die den
europameisterschaften da man eigentlich
sie die bedenken das war so viele
menschen zusammenkommen
die gab es schon auf der anderen seite
sagen die italiener auch wir müssen
irgendwann aus normalität zurückkehren
und wenn wir das mit vorsicht tun ist
das auch in ordnung
die mannschaft italiener war ja lange
nicht so richtig erfolgreich bei der wm
für 18 waren sie gar nicht dabei bei der
em 216 haben sie das elfmeterschießen
gegen deutschland verloren im
viertelfinale gegen die italiener da
heute wirklich mit der hoffnung daran
dass sie das reisen können wie die
türkei oder sind sie einfach nur froh
dass sie überhaupt wieder zusammen
fußball gucken können
also sehen auf jeden fall unglaublich
froh dass sie wieder dabei sind und
brennend für ihre mannschaft und
tatsächlich ist hier auch seit 2008
seien wesentlich erfolgreicher seitdem
sie in 2010 wurde ja neuer trainer
gewonnen das ist roberto mancini und
herren eine komplett andere neue
mannschaft geformt die sehr
teamorientiert das sind zwar auch die
erfahrenen spieler noch dabei aber auch
sehr viele junge spieler sehr begabte
spieler die spielen einen modernen
dynamischen aufregenden fußball der bei
dem publikum auch sehr gut ankommt mit
kurzpassspiel und man hoffte wieder
jederzeit sehen sich sogar als
geheimfavorit und sagen gehen davon aus
dass dieses halbfinale auf jeden fall
erreichen kann
da bin ich mal gespannt was unsere
sportexperten vielleicht dazu sagen hier
rom ist ja nur einer von elf
austragungsorten in europa und in asien
durch aserbaidschan jonas post hat mal
dieses ganze bunte spektakel für uns
zusammengefasst
24 teams spielen bis zum 11 juli den
europameister aus stadien elf städten
quer über europa verteilt von sevilla in
spanien hoch bis nach glasgow im osten
sankt petersburg und baku aserbaidschan
als hauptstadt heute der beginn in rom
beim finale in london könnten bis zu
90.000 menschen im stadion sein
allerdings steht die aufhebung der
letzten noch geltenden corona
beschränkungen gerade wieder auf der
kippe
nur 14.000 menschen sind dagegen in
münchen zugelassen
die deutsche nationalmannschaft spielt
hier alle ihre vorrundenspiele
so habe jetzt ganz viele kommentare ja
gerade die fragen ob wir das spiel hier
übertragen in diesem screen da muss ich
euch enttäuschen das ist nicht der fall
aber wir erwarten mit euch quasi das ja
nicht ganz bis zum anpfiff aber ungefähr
den könnt ihr dann bei den kollegen von
der ard sehen aber ard und zdf
übertragen das spektakel wie immer
gemeinsam immer im wechsel das heißt
auch hier werden wir euch im laufe der
em bedienen annette das erste spiel in
rom türkei gegen italien unter welchen
bedingungen findet das statt also im
stadion selber gelten genau solche
auflagen wie sie hier draußen auch
gelten
es darf nur ein viertel des
olympiastadions was ja hier ein bisschen
nördlich weiter nördlich liegt am tiber
ufer darf gefüllt sein
das sind 15 1900 menschen und wenn man
dieses riesen stadion mal gesehen hat in
dem normalerweise der as rom und lazio
rom abwechselnd spielen da sind 72.600
80 plätze verfügbar
da kann man sich vorstellen wie viel
abstand da letztendlich auch da sein
wird wenn man reinkommt muss man
zunächst mal musste man sich ja
registrieren
man musste vorweisen dass man negativ
test hat oder geimpftes und selbst
trotzdem am eingang werden 38 thermo
scanner stehen um zu beobachten ob die
menschen auch tatsächlich kein fieber
haben und reinkommen es soll auf keinen
fall gedränge geben
selbst die spielerbank da sind die sitze
so anderthalb meter auseinander
dass also auch da keine berührungspunkte
sind ich habe mich sehr dass dem spiel
zu dritt alles gut mache ich weiter
ja wie sehr das im spiel der stimmung
während des spieles zuträglich sein wird
oder nicht oder ob vielleicht dabei war
der enthusiasmus und die freude darüber
endlich wieder vor publikum spielen zu
können und endlich wieder die eigene
mannschaft sehen zu können da überwiegt
das werden wir dann noch sehen einen
vorteil hat das ganze man kriegt
wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell ein
bierbecher ab ich hab mich meine
spielplan gestürzt am dritten juli
könnte das deutsche team tatsächlich das
viertelfinale in rom bestreiten wenn es
gruppen zweiter wird und dann das
achtelfinale in london ende juni am 29
juni gewinnt wäre es dann für deutsche
fans ohne probleme möglich nach rom zu
kommen um das spiel da irgendwie gucken
zu können
also die anreise ist mittlerweile völlig
unproblematisch das heißt sogar dass ab
montag rom also die gegend um rom als
latium weiße zone wird das heißt die
beschränkungen werden weitgehend
aufgehoben bleibt bleibt immer noch die
masken pflicht aber ehrlich gesagt für
die echten fans ist das glaube ich kein
problem
was die karten angeht die werden ja von
der uefa verteilt oder gehen auch immer
einen teil an sponsoren das ist auch
dieses mal so gewesen sodass also auf
dem markt von den 15.000 900 karten wenn
es denn dabei bleibt letztendlich dann
nicht so viele auf dem markt sein werden
aber wir haben mir ein paar glückliche
getroffen heute auch deutsche die
tickets hatten
es ist also nicht unmöglich aber hotels
unterkünfte die gibt es noch und das ist
auch ohne probleme buchbar
also ich glaube die römer an römerinnen
freuen sich über jeden besucher der
momentan kommt die korona zeit ist ja
doch sehr hart gewesen für die gesamte
gastronomie und die hotellerie und
inzwischen merkt man schon dass es
wieder mehr besucher gibt es gibt mehr
rollkoffer die wieder über die
kopfsteinpflaster holtmann und man hört
auch wieder andere sprachen
und die italiener freuen sich da
wahnsinnig darüber weil ja ja
letztendlich leben sie leben viele in
rom vom tourismus und freuen sich eben
wenn es wieder viel mehr besucher kommen
und sagen herzlich willkommen benvenuto
am ettelsberg vielen dank für diese
eindrücke aus rom und dann wünsche ich
dir einen schönen fußballabend
aber bis die deutsche mannschaft
tatsächlich in rom spielen könnte da
muss sie noch ein paar andere spiele
schaffen und heute war nochmal
pressetermin heiko klaas nach die bilder
gute stimmung teamgeist und
mannschaftliche geschlossenheit sind
durchaus hilfreich beim fotoshooting und
auch im spiel
genau diese trümpfe nämlich will das dfb
team bei der em aus spielen am besten
gleich zum auftakt gegen frankreich mein
gefühl ist eigentlich eigentlich ganz
gut nur wie gesagt am ende der tage geht
es dann dienstag los und entscheidend
ist auf dem platz dort kann aus heiterem
himmel durchaus ungemach drohen mats
hummels kam am ende mit dem schrecken
davon anders jonas hofmann dem droht mit
einer knieverletzung die auszeit zur
unzeit
und bei mir im studio ist dass kathrin
müller-hohenstein unserer zdf sport
expertin katrin für fußball lux ihm ich
habe gerade für sie jetzt schon
einigermaßen ich habe gerade gesehen da
steht's um einige spieler nicht so
richtig super wie ist denn so generell
die kondition der deutschen mannschaft
die also eben möchtest du wissen ob die
deutsche mannschaft in der lage ist den
titel zu holen
das heißt die finale frage
verletzungsbedingte problemen also es
gibt natürlich da werden ja es werden
viele spieler so ein paar kleinere
wehwehchen haben wir dürfen nicht
vergessen die haben natürlich auch eine
wahnsinns saison hinter sich
also diese diese pandemie hat auch ich
will jetzt gar nicht an famila die die
sollen sie mal nicht so anstellen sind
aber es betrifft sie ja auch was du also
sie haben viele spiele gehabt teilweise
unter schwierigen bedingungen trainieren
müssen die saison war wahnsinnig lang
deswegen glaube ich dass
sich dass er innerhalb europas gar nicht
so sehr viel gibt weiß vorher jeder
betroffen davon also es wird keine
ausrede sein dass man sagen kann also
die sind jetzt aber körperlich nicht so
gut in schuss wie bei uns das vielleicht
vorgestellt hätten
weil es am ende wahrscheinlich ebenso
geht hast du denn favoriten also was
meinst du wer wird bevor nach das ist
innerhalb des teams oder oder oder
generell auch eine gute frage
innerhalb des teams also ich bin fan von
christian günther
das hatten ganz einfachen grund er war
zuletzt bei mir im sportstudio und ich
war sehr begeistert weil das ein
unglaublich reflektierter mensch auch
ist und ich finde das gehört zu einem
gesamtpaket eines fußballers auch dazu
ich glaube das wäre ich glaube dass wir
in aller erster linie tatsächlich eine
gute mannschaft haben und das ist
entscheidend am ende also wir haben
nicht diese diese vielen herausragenden
einzelspieler wobei die haben wir auch
also ein keil wird sein einiger kimmig
ein an die häuser also das sind spieler
nach denen sie sich jeder jedes jedes
große themen die finger lecken sondern
es ist ich glaube dass sie gut zusammen
funktionieren und das ist eine ganz gute
nachricht am heutigen generell generell
vor dem team sage ich sage seit weil man
es ja einfach nicht weiß woher das ist
die schlechte nachricht ich kann ihnen
nicht sagen europameister wird aber was
ich weiß nicht einmal
also ich sage seit seit jahrzehnten
eigentlich immer schon england wenn so
einen großen titel geht allein aus dem
grund dass der letzte eben sehr sehr
lange her ist und ich den eindruck habe
dass das vielleicht irgendwann mal
wieder passieren könnte ich würde die
engländer auch zu den favoriten
dazu zählen ich würde frankreich
natürlich als weltmeister wobei man weiß
es nicht vielleicht der ard dasselbe
schicksal wie die deutsche mannschaft
vielleicht sind die einfach auch schon
sagt du brauchst sie sie hier
er muss einfach gierig sein frankreich
würde ich trotzdem dazu rechnen und
belgien belgien ist ein team ist auch
immer wieder genannt wird seit vielen
jahren und es könnte sein dass es
diesmal klappt das ist einfach
durchziehen
erst heute abend favorit hat für mich ja
interessanterweise für mich italien da
ich kann es gar nicht so genau begründen
ich glaube es ist genau das was wir
gerade eben aus rom gehört haben dieses
gefühl wir sind jetzt wieder da und
jetzt werden was ein zeigen gehen danach
hat man die tiefe aber holen erst einmal
unseren
kollegen sven voss dazu der ist nämlich
in herzogenaurach wo die deutsche
mannschaft ihr quartier bezogen
hallo sven hallo genannt daniel kathrin
alles wenn das ganze ist ja kein
normales hotel was sie da gezogen haben
sondern das ist so eine art luxus
feriencamp irgendwie so wie sieht das
genauso wie sie das genau aus also eben
sagte mein teamkollege aljoscha hier das
hat schon was von urlaubsstimmung und
ich glaube man sitzt tatsächlich auch
hinter mir ich muss das ganz kurz
erklären wo wir sind wir sind natürlich
nicht mittendrin in der blase im
quartier der deutschen
nationalmannschaft sondern das ist ganz
streng getrennt hier hinter mir ist das
gebäude wo sich die presse auf halten
kann
links daneben sind unsere
übertragungswagen etc
und ganz ganz dahinten hinter dem
gebäude wo der sponsor wohnt sozusagen
da befindet sich dann das quartier und
da sind hohe zäune außen rum und dieses
camp man sieht sie auch noch mal aus der
luft das ist sehr luxuriös sehr
weitreichend und es erinnert so ein
bisschen an das camp in campo bei hier
an der brasilianischen atlantikküste wo
deutschland der 2014 weltmeister wurde
und ja das gibt viele gemeinsamkeiten es
gibt zum beispiel auch diese paar häuser
in denen die nationalspieler und die
trainer wohnen und in der mitte befindet
sich so ein marketplace und nennen sie
das auch einen großen pool und dort
trifft man sich also es geht viel um
team spirit und das findet hier
tatsächlich auch stadt hinter mehr
wie hat sich denn die mannschaft da
eingelegt also wie sieht so ein alltag
raus als die mannschaft am mittwoch hier
ankam da war die enttäuschung erstmal
groß denn da schüttete es wie aus eimern
hier in herzogenaurach und ja das war
erstmal kein so ein schöner empfang aber
dann am nächsten tag schien die sonne
und dann naja dann geht natürlich auch
der geregelte alltag für die
nationalspieler los wir sind ja auch
noch mal die bilder als der
mannschaftsbus dann hier ankam
ich glaube die englischen
nationalspieler fühlten sich ja in
london erinnert aber dann am nächsten
tag wie gesagt dann geht das ganze sein
gang dann wird natürlich erst mal das
gelände inspiziert
die jungs haben hier fahrräder auf ihrem
länder und können dort sich frei bewegen
und fahren dann mal runter zum
trainingsplatz neben dran ist dann auch
so ein kleines fitness gym da hat der
eine oder andere auch schon auf dem
fahrrad gesessen und dann klar geht es
ins training und anschließend das sind
meine pressekonferenz einzelne spieler
geben dann noch einzelinterviews und ja
dann ist er der rest des tages nicht
ganz zur freien verfügung natürlich geht
alles im hinblick auf dieses spiel gegen
frankreich so ab dass man natürlich die
analysen hat aber noch mal dieser spirit
entsteht dann wenn die einzelnen spieler
sich treffen wenn sie sich so kleine
gemeinschaften bilden und
freizeitaktivitäten die gibt es hier
natürlich auch es gab glaube ich auch
mal eine runde golf thomas müller und
manuel neuer waren da ganz vorne mit
dabei
das fand ihr luftlinie fünf kilometer
statt
diese fahrräder ganze nicht nach
hochleistungssport aus er nach dem
gemütlichen einkaufsbummel dazu sagen
weil ich komme von da also eher
herzogenaurach ein kleiner ort der im
prinzip nur aus diesem weltklasse
sportartikel hersteller besteht und
eltern ganz schnell ans und zwar ist
eigentlich drei gewesen zwischendurch
auch so und dann gibt es nürnberg auf
der einen seite und erlangen auf der
anderen seite und herzogenaurach dass es
da wo lothar matthäus herkommt auch und
also dieses frankenland da ist halt aus
nürnberg und erlangen
dazwischen da ist nicht so wahnsinnig
viel zu tun das irre schön also die
fränkische schweiz kann ich der
mannschaft sehr empfehlen lieber sven
also du kannst da im prinzip ist es
deswegen schon wie campo bei hier weil
auch da waren wir mitten in einem jahr
gefühlt im dschungel und da da gab es
sonst nix und das ist da ein bisschen
ähnlich
ich suche seit zwei tagen die katrin
müller-hohenstein straße hier aber noch
nicht gefunden aber ansonsten finde ich
das ganz kurz zeigen
das ist natürlich schon eine attraktion
dass hier so viel los ist und auch sich
das medienspektakel in gewisser weise
abspielt hier sind einige die jetzt dem
fahrrad hier noch hoch kommen hier auf
der brücke stehen einfach mal den
ausblick genießen und ich glaube das
sieht man auch also ich glaub das wird
in den nächsten tagen noch mehr
allerdings und das ist die bittere
erkenntnis natürlich kommt man nicht
mehr an die nationalmannschaft ran denn
die befindet sich ja in ihrem camp in
ihrem home grown
das war ja ein kampf wobei hier katrin
genau so dass
wieder zusammengelebt haben in soja im
zimmer gibt's immer wer schläft mit
leben das war ja irgendwie psychologisch
zusammengesetzt habe ich herrn erfahren
ist das jetzt genau so sven dass man
genau geguckt hat wer geht mit wem
welches baumhaus baumhäuser sind es
nicht aber es sind tatsächlich so zu
hüten
da können bis zu fünf personen rein das
sind dann einzelne zimmer es gibt jetzt
keinen gemeinschaftsraum das findet wie
gesagt zwischen den häusern statt bei
gutem wetter natürlich rund um den pool
aber ansonsten war das wirklich ganz
spannendes wurden die sieben häuser
wurden erstmal da wurden sieben häuser
kapitäne sozusagen festgelegt nach
anzahl der spiele die sich schon für die
nationalmannschaft gemacht hatten und da
war natürlich die jungs im hunderter
club manuel neuer an voran die gehörten
dazu und dann gab es diese sieben
kapitän und dann wurden die anderen
nationalspieler zugelost und dann wurde
es aber ganz spannend dann wurde wohl
nochmal gefeilscht und dann übrigens
glücklich so wie früher mit den panini
karten ich geb den amritsar dafür
kriechen gündogan und so weiter also das
war was ganz spannend gewesen sein aber
ich habe heute mit mats hummels sprechen
können der ist mit niklas süle und kevin
volland in der dreier wg und der war
eigentlich ganz angetan und der war
rundum zufrieden von seinen ersten
eindrücken was ich ganz spannend finde
ist wenn er in brasilien war es ja so
die waren natürlich in ihrem eigenen
areal aber der strand war für alle
zugänglich das heißt es war möglich dass
du da die spieler trifft auch den
bundestrainer trifft weil die da eben
immer abgehauen sind
wo ist das leck im zaun des deutschen
quartiers in herzogenaurach
hast du dich schon entschwinden sehen ja
es gab tatsächlich wir haben ganz
pfiffige kameraleute die dann
tatsächlich auch mal ein bisschen näher
rankommen und dann gab es eine begegnung
wo unser baby der kameramann der war
relativ nah
robin großen es natürlich alles mit
abstand wir sind ja auch alle hier
getestet insofern keine gefahr
aber der konnte dann tatsächlich ihnen
beim einsteigen ins auto beim aussteigen
ins auto relativ nahe zeigen es gibt
immer wieder diese kleinen lücken aber
ansonsten ist das schon relativ
wasserdicht und man braucht kathrin weiß
es einen offiziellen termin um ein
interview zu machen mit einem
nationalspieler aber hey was robin
goosens sehen wir ins auto eingestiegen
und wieder ausgestiegen ist das ist es
ist natürlich irre was wir für was sie
für nachrichten produzieren in diesen
zeiten aber so ist das geschäft
ich freue mich auf die nächste bus
ankunft dreiviertelstunde der bus rollt
an
ich habe eine frage ich weiß nicht ob so
was raus gedrungen ist aber wie amazing
in den mann
er spielt darauf an dass ist ja ein
gespräch gab mit der bundeskanzlerin und
der deutschen mannschaft war gab es so
eine art videokonferenz- und der möchte
wissen welche frage war besonders
interessant die von der mannschaft am
einer merkel gestellt wurde ist
überhaupt irgendwas raus gedrückt werden
über dieses gespräch nicht richtig aber
wir haben gehört dass natürlich alle
beeindruckt waren gerade diejenigen die
noch nicht so lange dabei sind die jetzt
zum ersten mal den kontakt mit der
bundeskanzlerin hatten und wir wissen ja
dass die bundeskanzlerin sehr
fußballinteressiert ist und auch
interessante fachfragen stellt und dann
ging das ganze aber auch zurück und
tatsächlich konnten die nationalspieler
auf fragen stellen und ich glaube es war
robin großes das ist so durchgedrungen
der dann auch erst mal wissen wollte wie
die kanzlerin denn jetzt in dieser
ganzen pandemie das land gesteuert hat
also dass zum thema horizont da gehen
die fußballer auch gedanklich aus ihrer
blase raus und interessieren sich
natürlich für das was in deutschland
passiert
ich habe jetzt hier im chat ganz viele
vor allem türkische fans habe ich
festgestellt musste aber erst mal
verstehen was das heißt wir hier stehen
solange dritte drittel und dann hab ich
gerade verstanden okay also ihr seid für
die türkei zum größten teil zumindest
das werden kannst du uns eine tendenz
mit geben welche sieger hätte die
deutsche mannschaft lieber heute abend
das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht also
ich kann mir vorstellen da bin ich
wieder bei robin grossmann davos spielt
er hat natürlich einige spezies
im süden von europa und damit meine ich
italien und ich kann mir vorstellen dass
er sich schon über dieses quadra so
erfreut aber natürlich gerade in
deutschland gibt es viele fans der
türkischen nationalmannschaft und ich
weiß gar nicht ob sich da einer
festlegen will aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass amerika gündogan schon
auch ein auge auf die türkische
nationalmannschaft werfen insgesamt muss
man sagen die kennen sich ja mehr oder
weniger alles spinale champions league
die treffen sich immer mal wieder die
besten spieler europas und von daher
weiß ich nicht genau sie gucken es aber
entweder auf ihrem zimmer oder eben
gemeinschaftlich dann in diesem
marketplace oder auf diesem marketplace
acht die gucken sicher zusammen und ich
bin mir relativ sicher dass du von
keinem der spieler eine offizielle
aussage darüber bekommen wirst leben
heute abend die daumen drückt aber wir
können schon mal festhalten hopping
großen steigt in ein auto und wieder aus
robin groß stellt der kanzlerin kluge
fragen und ist vermutlich heute abend
für die italiener weiter in bergamo
steht also dass er wird vermutlich der
liebling der medien werden
jetzt gab es ja an den bundestrainer ein
bisschen ernsthafter jetzt haben doch
relativ viel kritik in den letzten
monaten kannst du das noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen
die kritik am bundestrainer also ich
glaube das würde jetzt den rahmen der
sendung sprengen auch wenn wir in einem
livestream sind sticht falsche taktik
falsche spieler im prinzip alles falsch
was er gemacht hat
aber das ist nicht immer so ich mag am
ende standen natürlich die die falschen
die falschen resultate und dass das
ausscheiden in der vorrunde bei der wm
in russland das war der super gau ist
schlimmer geht es nicht so und er sich
davon zu erholen
es werden vielleicht kannst du halten
wort noch dazu sagen wie joachim löw auf
mich wirkt aber ich hab den eindruck der
ist total gelassen
also ich glaube das stichwort ist
tatsächlich wm 2018 dieses frühe
ausscheiden in russland und danach war
es ja nicht nur der dfb und die
nationalmannschaft die darüber
nachgedacht haben wie geht es jetzt
weiter sondern es würde ja auch in der
öffentlichkeit diskutiert und da waren
sie auch alle experten und alle 80
millionen bundestrainer einig dass es so
nicht weitergehen kann und dann gab es
eben diesen
reflex die ausbootung von boateng müller
hummels wissen wir alle
das war vielleicht ein bisschen
schwierig kommuniziert aber dann sollte
der neuanfang oder diese kleine
revolution ja starten und dann hat man
aber spätestens beim 0 6 gegen spanien
festgestellt so funktioniert dann doch
nicht und das finde ich muss man den
bundestrainer hoch anrechnen dass er da
von seiner idee auch abgewichen ist und
hat das finde ich dann auch sehr gut
kommuniziert die spieler wieder bis mit
ins boot geholt und mein sohn hat mir
heute noch mal gesagt im interview dass
da auch nichts hängengeblieben ist die
haben alle gemeinsam jetzt ja die sind
auf wiedergutmachungs mission und
joachim löw man man sagt dem ja manchmal
so eine gewisse teflon artigkeit nach an
dem prallt alles ab aber ganz ehrlich
ich halte ihn für einen sehr
feinfühligen menschen er kriegt das mit
werner gegenwind bekommt und setzt sich
damit mit seinem trainerteam auseinander
und kathrin wenn man ihn hier beobachtet
das sind eigentlich die bilder wie immer
erst gelöst er ist entspannt der machen
die man witzchen und kickt den ball
selber noch mal um die ecke und hat
immer anspruch auch für die journalisten
und das macht einen sehr guten eindruck
also alle die gesagt haben joachim löw
nach seiner bekanntgabe er wird nach
diesem turnier nicht mehr weitermachen
seine lahme ente
das glaube ich ist nicht so also die
gier von kathrin leben gesprochen hast
ich finde die ist ihm schon anzumerken
und mein gefühl sagt mir dass die
mannschaft auch zu 100 prozent hinter
ihm steht und für ihn
um diesen titel mitspielen will ich habe
einen kommentar von feierabend der meint
löw fehlt die nötige selbstreflektion
wird ihr das nähe das ist jetzt genau
die frage was ist selbstreflexion
es ist ja nicht so dass joachim löw
etwas entscheidet und alle 80 millionen
sind sich einig dass aber nur dieser weg
funktioniert sondern du hast löws weg
und du hast gefühlt 80 millionen andere
wege also was ist da die selbst war ich
glaube dass du dich irgendwann insofern
auch schützen musst dass du sagst okay
ich bin derjenige der hier den hut
aufhat ich bin derjenige der auch mit
den konsequenzen leben muss also muss
ich meine entscheidungen fällen so und
das ist seine vorstellung der autorität
und dem fußball den er spielen lassen
wollte also was ich nicht glaube schon
dass der das ja
der lage ist selbstreflexion und wenn du
sagst glaube zur selbstreflektion gehört
ja auch dass man die größe hat auch
fehler einzugestehen dass dauerte ein
bisschen glaube ich aber irgendwann war
es ja tatsächlich mit dem signal ja ich
glaube das ist eine ganz gute idee mit
müller und hummels dann doch wieder zu
dazu spielen und auch die jüngeren
spieler zu unterstützen und vielleicht
wirklich auf deren qualitäten auch
wieder zurück zu greifen
das ist für mich ein zeichen von größe
und ich hoffe dass es so auch
funktionieren jetzt gibt ja dieses jahr
bei der europameisterschaft in paris
änderungen na da sind ein paar sachen
neu jonas post esch hat die nur für uns
zusammengefasst
für die fußball-em 2021 gelten
verschiedene neue regeln
hier sind einige beispiele bei dieser em
kommt zum ersten mal ein video assistent
zum einsatz
dieser soll aber nur bei klaren und
offensichtlichen fehlern des
schiedsrichters eingreifen oder wenn ein
schiedsrichter eine wichtige szene auf
dem spielfeld nicht gesehen hat der
video assistent darf sich einschalten
wenn es um tore elfmeter und rote karten
geht oder der schiedsrichter spieler bei
einer persönlichen strafe wie eine
verwarnung verwechselt
außerdem gilt eine neue regel für das
handspiel nicht mehr jede ballberührung
mit arm oder hand ist automatisch ein
vergehen
strafbar ist das handspiel nur wenn es
absichtlich passiert oder der spieler
seine körperfläche mit arm oder hand und
natürlich vergrößert wann das der fall
ist entscheiden die schiedsrichter wie
auch in der bundesliga dürfen die
trainer pandemie bedingt während eines
matches fünfmal spieler auswechseln
allerdings darf jede mannschaft dafür
das spiel nur dreimal unterbrechen und
zusätzlich die halbzeitpause nutzen
kommt es zur verlängerung ist ein
weiterer wechsel möglich also dass habe
ich eine frage an euch beiden wie
vergrößert man mit der handfläche seinen
eigenen körper könnten hartz iv oder
machen also die muss das macht jetzt das
man hat wenn wie ich den vergrößern
naja wenn ich den arm so heberin sieht
dann kann ich natürlich die möglichkeit
an den ball zu kommen wenn er denn in
die richtung fliegt dann habe ich die
körper fläche vergrößert wenn ich aber
so hoch springen und dabei geht an mir
vorbei dann habe ich sie nicht
vergrößert und dann fällt auch kein
schwierig also eine relativ einfache
erklärung für ein relativ kommt nix ich
aber das ist ja immer schon relativ
produzierten ausdruck wie kommen diese
regeländerungen dfb team ins rennen
das weiß ich im einzelnen nicht ich
finde eine der wichtigen außerdem über
eine der wichtigsten wichtigsten
regeländerungen ich ja ich glaube eine
der wichtigsten regelungen und gerade in
diesen zeiten ist dass die uefa
natürlich sehr kulant ist was die
nachnominierung von spielern betrifft
und das gab es ja so auch noch nicht nur
also spanien zum beispiel die hatten
jetzt zwei falsch positive fälle und die
hätten aber im hintergrund in spanien
schon ein b-team ein schatten team
gehabt auch in der eigenen blase 17
spieler die da bereit sind und auf die
man zugreifen könnte um dann die spieler
die hier isoliert werden und in
quarantäne geschickt werden dann zu
ersetzen ich glaube das ist was wo die
läufer natürlich sich sicher ist wir
können dieses turnier auch durchziehen
auch wenn es einen corona fall geben
sollte und auf der anderen seite
natürlich auch für die einzelnen
nationalmannschaften hoher aufwand aber
natürlich auch so ein kleiner sicherheit
und was davor schon entscheiden war die
durften 26 spieler nominieren und nicht
23 und das hat zur folge gehabt dass wir
auch im laufenden jahr überhaupt
niemanden
wolfen musste also musste man hause
schicken er konnte alle mitnehmen ich
glaube dass das schon auch ein vorteil
ist wie das passieren als wenn wenn
jetzt tatsächlich waren corinna
positiven auftritt also gab's ja eben
schon geschildert dass das dieses netz
doch sehr lückenlos ist
stand jetzt nah und klar gehen die auch
auf reisen dann aber auch da bleiben
sind ihrer blase klar gibt es auch in
dieser hotelanlage oder in dieser
apartmentanlage gibt es auch personal
aber klar das wird jeden tag getestet
auch wir werden jeden tag getestet bevor
es irgendeinen kontakt gibt aber klar
dass wir uns das wissen wir ist
wählerisch und sehr trickreich und es
könnte natürlich passieren und dann
würde natürlich der spieler und die
spieler die kontakt zu einem positiv
getesteten spieler haben würden isoliert
werden in quarantäne geschickt werden
und dann wird entschieden also ja aber
das muss ja nicht sein dass das man das
gleich die ganze mannschaft
beziehungsweise der ganze kader
infiziert ist also ich hatte selber
corona und ich weiß wie es ist innerhalb
einer familie ist das virus so
wählerisch das ist sagt du kriegst es
und du kriegst es nicht jetzt wollte er
läuft ja nach der misslungenen wm
kathrin eigentlich alles neu machen also
komplette revolution das ist jetzt nicht
ganz gelungen da sind so ein paar
gesichter dabei die kennt man schon von
früher
woran ist denn das gescheitert das ist
jetzt nicht quasi ein komplettes so wie
es ist daran gescheitert dass er jetzt
weiß dass er nach dieser em nicht
weitermachen wird und deswegen in der
situation ist ein umbruch nicht mehr
moderieren zu müssen nicht mehr
durchführen zu müssen soll wer kann
einfach sagen nehmt die beste mannschaft
mit die wir jetzt im juni 2021 haben und
da gehören dann ebenso spieler wie
thomas müller und mats hummels eindeutig
dazu wissen von vorteil davon nach da
ist wenn das läuft nach der em safe
ausscheidet ich habe es ja eben schon
angedeutet ich halte es von vorteil
tatsächlich und auch den den zeitpunkt
an dem das bekanntgegeben hat das hat
dem dfb dann auch ermöglicht zu sagen
okay dann gehen wir jetzt auch in dieses
turnier weil ich glaube ein
kurzfristiger wechsel auf der
bundestrainer position der hätte
natürlich einiges durcheinander gebracht
also joachim löw kennt dieses system
nationalmannschaft und erkennt diese
mannschaft in und auswendig erhalten
plant den kann man gut finden oder nicht
gut finden da gibt es
wir leben schon bei dem thema genügend
die auch sagen er hätte schon viel
früher abgelöst werden müssen aber es
gibt viele die ihm vertrauen und ich
glaube deswegen ist es auch eine
richtige entscheidung
mit dem bundestrainer in dieses turnier
zu gehen und danach stellt man die
weichen noch mal neu aber natürlich
wissen wir alle dass das ganze sehr
ergebnis abhängig ist und es wird
spannend wie weit kommt die deutsche
mannschaft wie sehr funktioniert dieses
system wie wir es jetzt haben und
katharina eben angedeutet in dieser
konstellation hat die deutsche
mannschaft noch nicht zusammengespielt
dementsprechend auch noch nicht verloren
das wird spannend ich danke euch beiden
für ihre expertise und jetzt habe ich
euch noch eine sache zeigen dann haben
bitte sehr gerne
ja weil wir eben eine über
urlaubsstimmung gesprochen haben und
jetzt denkt vielleicht der ein oder
andere mensch der foster hat irgendwie
ein magen knurren aber das ist es nicht
es sind die tatsächlich frösche oder
kröten da kann man da eine oder andere
bio lehrer vielleicht weiterhelfen aber
das ist hier kathrin in deiner heimat
hier da gibt es diese rasche gab's
wollte zwei jahre lang in frankreich bei
den frauen auch ich weiß noch aber es
war dann am ende doch überbewertet so
schlimm war es am ende mich aber ist
wunderschön
wir sind kurz davor die alle zu taufen
gut bevor wir jetzt partner
patenschaften für einzelne porsche
übernehmen sagt vielen dank euch beiden
aber ich habe hier schon ein tipp von
east germany industrie italien 5 0 ist
möchte ich eure beiden tipps würden aber
ich habe heute morgen schon 31 gesagt
deswegen bleibe ich einfach mal dabei 31
italien 10 italien
okay das ist relativ eindeutig deshalb
favorit ist wir sind gespannt 21 uhr
geht's los bei den kollegen von der ard
aber bleibt noch dran denn wir schalten
vielleicht noch weiter vorher gucken uns
aber an die dir eigentlich gucken können
die koreaner zahlen sehen ja eigentlich
ganz gut aus in deutschland aber
natürlich ist weiterhin vorsicht
angesagt und romanesco ba hat es für uns
mal zusammengefasst wie wir fußball
gucken können die bewohner dieses
berliner hauses schon in voller em
stimmung flatternde fahnen aller
teilnehmerländer ansonsten noch nicht so
viel zu sehen von typischer
fußballbegeisterung kroner bedingt große
events wie die fanmeile am brandenburger
tor
gesagt unterschiedlich die folge also
bei mir ist es auf alle fälle da das
wm-fieber ich werde gucken
ich habe mich auch dementsprechend
vorbereitet aber soll diese euphorie ist
noch nicht da aber auch den eindruck in
der öffentlichkeit dass das gar nicht so
intensiv wahrgenommen wird wie es schon
mal so war
einige veranstalter setzen trotzdem auf
public viewing im berliner soda club
sogar mit 32 quadratmeter screen unter
strengem hygiene konzept registriert und
corona testpflicht auch in zoll parkhof
biergarten ist alles etwas kleiner
geraten nur vier bildschirme auf denen
auch nicht alle spiele gezeigt werden
der technische aufwand ist auch bei
kleinerer besetzung ist natürlich auch
immens jeden haben müssen die technik
wieder zurück geräumt werden muss
bewacht werden angebote zum public
viewing wird es vielerorts geben in
deutschland wie auch hier in düsseldorf
und auch wenn sich im biergarten viele
auf die em freuen
vorsichtig wollen sie trotzdem bleiben
wären sozusagen sich dreimal getestet
hat ja so wie wir das hier gemacht haben
ich glaube dann ist es halbwegs in
ordnung die meisten irgendwie auch ein
oder zwei mal schon mal im freudentaumel
dieses jahr aber auf jeden fall tabu
stattdessen fußballschauen im kleineren
kreis was durchaus auch spaß machen kann
das kann es auf jeden fall und wie das
gelingen kann das haben wir unsere
beiden reporter gefragt ja wir
rausgeschickt einmal thomas münten in
solingen uns den klarsten stuttgart
hannover 2 ich fange mal beim sven an du
bist draußen sehe ich in stuttgart und
ich glaube bei einem italienischen
restaurants richtig so ist es ein
italienisches restaurant in der
stadtmitte und wir sehen hinter uns auch
das steht der fernseher die
vorberichterstattung hat gerade
angefangen und wir sehen auch relativ
genau es sind ungefähr 30 menschen die
sich hier heute abend für fußball
interessieren
und wenn wir mal nach da drüben gucken
das sind alle anderen die hier heute
abend essen sind also vor freude
naja bei ein paar leuten ist sie
durchaus schon da aber ich glaube die
muss noch wachsen
und wenn wir auch mal in die andere
richtung kommt haben wir in prag ich
weiß nicht die bäume verdecken relativ
viel aber da sitzen einige noch beim
feierabend bierchen zusammen machen noch
ein bisschen sport also vorfreude sehen
wir bei ein paar leuten aber noch nicht
so richtig das ist ja das was wir auch
gerade beitrag schon gehört haben
du bist ja auch da einem restaurant
contest mit dem wirt sprechen was was
sagt er über seine gene konzept und wie
er erwartet dass es bei ihm funktioniert
ich kann mit dem wie entsprechen der ist
sogar bei uns deshalb bekommt gerade mal
ran
apple ist der betriebsleiter nämlich
hier was musstet ihr alles machen und
einhalten in diesem jahr damit ihr hier
überhaupt fußball übertragen könnte also
wir mussten einhalten einmal kontakt
blatt für jeden gast wo hier bei uns
ins restaurant kommt jeder gast muss
entweder gm zahlen oder einen
tagesaktuellen tester bei negativ eine
reservierung eineinhalb meter platz
zwischen den tischen unsere straßen
großen sonst nie ans licht die
hygienevorschriften einhalten und maske
beim laufen
okay und wir sind hier in stuttgart bei
einer inzidenz gerade knapp über 35 das
heißt hier gilt auch noch die regel wenn
man draußen unterwegs ist maximal zehn
personen aber aus maximal drei
haushalten das heißt ein schöner
fußballabend mit zehn freunden
funktioniert nicht aber das hat
funktioniert hier schon in der
vergangenheit du hast dein handy
mitgebracht und fotos von vergangenen
turnieren da waren nämlich hier auf
diesem platz auf dem wir jetzt stehen
teilweise 500 bis 1000 leute und dass
das so aus und wenn ja mal richtig
schaut das war die riesenleinwand die
wir hatten
und hier noch ein foto und natürlich
auch fotos von italienischen tifosi und
wenn ihr euch vorstellen dass hier jetzt
24 menschen sind den spiel angucken
wollen
italien und vor einigen jahren hier etwa
300 bis 1000 gäste daran ist es schon
und ganz ganz großer unterschied dass
alles nur nummer kleiner dieses
wir haben zwar viele auch hier in
stuttgart fußball übertragen allerdings
nicht mit den riesen riesengroßen
fernsehen sondern eher ein bisschen
kleiner
es gibt auch so kleine public viewing
veranstaltungen hier also nicht der
große platz in der mitte der stadt in
dem zehntausende menschen sind dicht an
dicht sondern eher so eine art
freiluftkinos wenn man dann auch mit
ordnern eingelassen wird einen platz
zugewiesen bekommt also mal schauen wie
sich das dann stimmungsmäßig alles
entwickelt wir können auch noch mal kurz
über das sportliche sprechen mit dir und
wir können auch cristiano noch dazu
nehmen du bist nämlich auch ein großer
fußballfan arbeite hier erst mal
vielleicht nur kurz noch bei dir
giuseppe hast du vor freude jetzt vor
dem turnier
gerade auch jetzt weil italien natürlich
das von mir in diesem jahr eröffnet ja
definitiv also meine vorfreude auf
fußball ist sehr groß freuen weil wir
die letzten eineinhalb jahren eigentlich
nicht so feiern konnten und die werden
ja auch verschoben worden ist und
italien hat dieses jahr eine super super
geile mannschaft und ich drücke ihm alle
daumen und das war schon gesagt du
traust und sogar den titel zu dieses
jahr dieses jahr ja ja
cristiano du wurdest mal angekündigt als
die größte fußball experte bei euch im
team
was traust du der mannschaft zu meinte
wegen italien gute mannschaft so fast
alle junge leute und die mächtig und
dann im mobile portal kann etwas machen
diese fußballmannschaft okay darf ich
euch noch einen tipp fragen für heute
abend für das auftaktspiel gegen die
türkei das jetzt gleich losgeht ich
denke in knapp 30 minuten so 32 31 die
türkei gewinnt so interessant
ich wäre 10 italien so mit den
eindrücken aus stuttgart kommen wir erst
mal wieder bei euch in mainz was haltet
ihr davon
und vielleicht kommen wir auch nach
solingen so thomas mann genau das wollen
wir das machen es sind vielen dank ich
finde ich den schönen fußballabend torte
stuttgart und wir gehen weiter nach
solingen thomas wo hast du dich denn
gerade eingeladen das sieht ja auch
gemütlich aus bei dir
das ist extrem gemütlich das ist schon
mal das wichtigste was man haben muss
nun relativ kleiner bildschirm zwar aber
kammer mit leben und hier haben wir
sozusagen die zuschauer hecke und bevor
ihr jetzt einen schock gekriegt und sagt
es ist aber die kleinste public viewing
veranstaltung der welt nein wir sind bei
familie china zu gast in solingen und
familie china ist gerade dabei sich zu
stärken für den bevorstehenden fußball
abend gegrillt wurde schon und jetzt
wird gegessen ganze familie plus
italienischer gast kommen wir gleich zu
und jetzt kommen wir erst mal zu herrn
china
ich gehe mal hier an der kamera vorbei
und dann müsstest du nicht einmal kurz
umdrehen erstmal guten appetit an alle
ansonsten ist das ja dieses jahr schon
irgendwie anders
normalerweise wäre mehr los ja wir haben
ja
im momentanen corinna zeit da sind wir
natürlich begrenzt hätten wir jetzt kein
corona gehabt dann werden wir mindestens
20 leute ja aber auch so der nachbar ist
gekommen der italienische gast spieler
ist da ist das heute abend auch so ein
bisschen beginn der fussball freude weil
bis jetzt hatte man ja immer noch was
ich heute morgen sollen der stadt hatte
ich auch so ein bisschen den eindruck so
richtig traut sich noch keiner dass das
zu feiern auch ja es ist natürlich auch
für uns sehr gut wir waren ja wir waren
ja eigentlich immer zu hause wir konnten
gar nicht feiern will kommt ja nicht
raus jetzt sind die zahlen auch sehr gut
runter wir können mit unserer freunde
nachbarn zusammen feiern und das freut
uns die zahlen in solingen sind heute
unter 30 schon den fünften tag das heißt
in zwei tagen ist dann die nächste stufe
der lockerung erreicht wenn die türkei
dann beim nächsten mal spielt wird die
party deutlich größer also wir hoffen
dass die zahlen natürlich runter gehen
wenn die zahlen runter gehen sollten
dann werden wir wahrscheinlich auf jeden
fall die restlichen letzten monaten
nachholen dann bestimmt mit mehreren
leuten hier
ich sage dir schon mal vielen dank ist
ruhig weiter lassen die stirn wir kommen
nämlich dann mal zu unseren beiden
jungen fußballern immer hinten herum und
komme zu euch beiden vereine hat schon
aufgegessen der andere noch nicht so
ganz
als alles billig und karim
du verbringst den das erste spiel der
mannschaft für die duh fremd sieht man
ja hier am trinken ganz deutlich da ist
sie kann man verbringst du bei den
sportlichen sagen wir mal konkurrenten
warum das ja ein guter freund es uns ja
es freut mich eigentlich hier zu sein
deswegen ja macht eigentlich auch spaß
müssen
ich habe meine eltern gesagt hat gesagt
dass ich gehe jetzt sogar und gucke bei
den sportkameraden gegen uns spielen ja
monate haben sich eigentlich gefreut
also ich hab ja eigentlich ganz normal
kommen wir mal zum sportlichen aspekt
wenn man einen italien trikot anhat dann
ist man natürlich auch irgendwie italien
trennen
was denkst du denn wir das spiel heute
ausgeht ich hoffe auf einen 31 sind
italiener so gut
guck mal was er wenig dazu sagen kann
man das so hinnehmen diesem jahr nicht
viel besser ich habe die spiele von
italien gesehen aber trotzdem ich habe
die spieler von italien nicht gesehen
haben ja gar nicht angeguckt woher kennt
ja bei durch ihr kennt euch vom fußball
seit acht jahren ungefähr
ich will meine selben mannschaft im
fußball und haben mit kennengelernt und
angefreundet
du bist ein ganz ruhiger vertreter der
italiener der kommt aus sich raus haben
wir eben schon mal waren die letzten
monate mit ja bitte immer dazwischen
lagen das was passiert denn wenn jetzt
einer von ihren beiden mannschaften
ausscheidet gehen sie dann rüber und
sind dann für die deutsche mannschaft
oder haben sie noch eine andere
alternativ mannschaft die sie anfeuern
möchten gute frage gute frage
der daniel im studio fragt was passiert
denn wenn einer von unseren beiden
mannschaften außer wenn die italiener
als ausscheiden würden was natürlich
nicht vorkommen
für wen würdest du dich dann entscheiden
auf der sozusagen auf der fanbase zu
stehen
dann glaube ich in frankreich weil ich
mag eigentlich frankreich also sind die
spieler auch serien zu das lässt mich
jetzt traurig zurück
aber du hast eben schon gesagt du bist
auch nicht so überzeugt dass die
italiener unbedingt europameister werden
das team ist ganz okay aber es gibt eine
bessere teams und das beste wäre
frankreich portugal
in das spiel gehen und vielleicht auch
türkei weil so was sagst du werden die
türkei ausscheidet für wem bist du das
einfach ich mag die spieler dort bin ich
aufgewachsen ich lebe hier
das wird ganz spannend ihr müsst ihr
schnell essen war gleich im spiel los
dann müssen alle rein und natürlich
gucken und ich sage vielen dank dass ihr
bier bei diesem relativ kleinen public
viewing dabei sein dürften und mittwoch
die türkei gewinnt wird das dann
deutlich lauter ganz kurz nach jeder
wahl gibt es heute abend irgendwie
glaubst du noch ein autokorso falls ich
doch kein gewinnt oder sind alle von den
pflichten
also ich denke mal türkei wert gewinnen
ich tippe auf 2 1 für die türkei ich
drücke italien meine damen alle meine
daumen die ich habe aber nicht heute und
mit diesen daumen drücken heute mal
nicht würdig seit jänner geben wir gerne
zurück nach mainz und freuen uns dass
wir hier übrigens alle ich geimpft
kameraleute geimpfte insoweit brauchen
wir hier ausnahmsweise mal im freien
keine masken bevor sich jemand auf mich
zugekommen ist
vielen dank thomas für diese eindrücke
und ich glaube wenn wir mal wieder neue
sportexperten brauchen hast du schon den
nachwuchs da bei dir das ist wundervoll
in diesem sinne einen schönen gruß nach
solingen lasst euch noch schmecken und
einen schönen fußballabend und den
wünsch ich euch jetzt auch im stream
die kollegen von der ard übernehmen
gleich 21 uhr da ist der anpfiff aber
natürlich alle infos auch hier bei uns
im zdf-sportstudio punkt de da findet
ihr alles was wir wissen möchte die
nächsten spiele gibt es auch hier im zdf
zu sehen von daher die teilen uns dass
brüderlich und schwesterlich auf habe
für heute sage ich erst mal danke fürs
zu sehen danke für eure kommentare möge
das team gewinnen für das ihr heute
abend sein und bis zum nächsten mal
macht gut und tschüss
[Musik]